Perez man thank you so much for being
here I'm happy to be here so for those
of you and unfortunately I can't hear
Perez right now so hopefully in the
control room they'll figure that out
Perez Hilton is the most prominent
blogger in Hollywood history
yeah he doesn't need an introduction but
I'll give him one anyway he really he
was one of the first bloggers period
certainly the biggest one out here in
la-la land
now Hollywood is crumbling groped by
grope and we are lucky to have the
number one expert on behind the scenes
machinations Perez my first question is
this the end for Hollywood I definitely
don't think that everything that's
happened as the result of this Harvey
Weinstein scandal will very negatively
impact Hollywood you know Hollywood is a
very forgiving town I don't think that
he will be able to have a comeback what
I do think will happen as a result of
this is we as a world and a community
here in Los Angeles are now creating a
culture where we're letting women know
that it is okay for them to speak out
that they will be supportive that they
will be heard understood and believed do
you think though I mean ice it's
obviously people are pouring out there's
this bandwagon now that Harvey Weinstein
has been exposed formerly the biggest
guy in town now he's being run out on a
rail but is it just is it just the
bandwagon I mean I noticed people aren't
naming a whole lot of other names right
now does that culture where you're
afraid of saying the wrong thing about
the powerful people does that still
persist does this it's not even a
casting couch it's more like waste
sleazier than a casting couch is that is
this just we kicked a guy while he was
already falling out of power or as the
culture of Hollywood actually changing
well I pay very close attention to
everything happening and I I see the
opposite happening I've seen over the
last couple of weeks many other women
and men come forward sharing their very
personal stories about similar
experiences you know there was this very
well-known oscar-nominated director
recently over a hundred and ninety women
came forward and said he did all of
these inappropriate things to me
there was a Hollywood talent agent a man
who was very inappropriate towards his
male client and others in that world and
it's a smaller scale things like this
has have been happening as well not just
in Hollywood but in other industries as
well I don't think this is a problem
that is exclusive to show business they
might not be exclusive it's certainly
amplified even just because we're all
watching it you know I mean we say this
is an industry where the the currency of
the industry our people you know when
you when you cast or when you audition
for a role the product is you so
obviously there's a natural intimacy
where lines can be blurred but you do
you I mean you pay as much attention to
this place as anybody probably much more
is there another shoe that's gonna drop
are there other big players that are
gonna fall other big institutions like
The Weinstein Company is this the is
this the end of this scandal or is it
only the beginning um I definitely don't
think it's the end of this scandal I
think that there will continue to be
developments along the way I mean just
today there were a report that The
Weinstein Company may have to file for
bankruptcy reports which I should add
they are denying but there have been
reports and accusations against Harvey
Weinstein's brother the Harvey specific
story is one that won't be going away
anytime soon
and the repercussions of that throughout
show business I think will be continued
to be felt for quite some time and you
know I actually give you some credit for
all of this obviously it's a you know
you started doing this to over ten years
ago and you were the first big blogger
and certainly the first big Hollywood
blogger but you really shone a light in
a way that other tabloids didn't really
do I mean you brought this kind of
Hollywood scrutiny and microscope into
the internet age and obviously there's a
lot of entertainment that goes along
with that as well do you take any any of
the credit or any of the responsibility
for ripping open the veil that covered
Hollywood for so long not at all
I would get credit first and foremost to
Ashley Judd she was the first major
player to speak on the record to be
fearless enough to put herself her
reputation in her career on the line in
speaking to the New York Times because
they had difficulty getting countless
women to speak on the record and she did
and she really let other women know it's
okay to share your story it's funny you
and I obviously probably have different
political views but when you look we on
the right we conservatives we always
like to make fun of crazy Hollywood
actors and actresses saying wild
political activist statements but then
when you when you look at what some of
these people have gone through in their
professional lives a lot of them since
they were children you get a little bit
more empathy I think and you say you
know this is a pretty weird town and
weird profession and if it if it changes
your mind and warps your vision of
things you know there but for the grace
of God go I possibly Ashley Judd is an
example because we all of we
conservatives made fun of her political
statements for the last two years my
last question for you what's the next
shoe to drop what is the next where is
this going
both the industry and the and obviously
this particular issue of the sexual
harassment and sexual assault I think
that
it remains to be seen I actually am a
little bit pessimistic I don't know
how much of a change it will have just
because by nature there are bad people
in this world and I do believe that this
will continue to happen just because
there are those that get a taste of
power and let it get to their head and
they will abuse those underneath them I
mean one of the other stories about
Harvey Weinstein that also resonated to
me wasn't that in addition to him
sexually harassing all these women
according to them was that according to
other women he was such a bully that he
would bully actresses allegedly to where
his wife Georgina Chapman is close she's
a fashion designer you know there will
always be those bullies there will
always be those higher ups that will
treat people beneath them awfully in
show business in politics across the
board
well politics is just show business for
ugly people as you know you're right
about the bullying and you see it with a
you know a lot of my friends who are
working at production houses or working
for a big agencies or whatever the
stories you hear of like phones being
thrown across the room and having to
work 20 hours straight engine it is
really vicious and even more so than I
think I've heard from my friends in
other high pressure fields like finance
or maybe politics is the only analog is
it the is it the narcissism is it the
vanity that comes along with show
business and politics that makes these
egos turn so monstrous no I think it's
the fact that for so long so many people
could get away with so much so much was
overlooked so much was accepted oh they
just do that that's been going on like
that forever whereas a more corporate
environment the more traditional
workplace would not accept and tolerate
behavior that is accepted and tolerated
in show business for politics there is a
permissiveness that's true you wouldn't
get it in a lot of other industries
where people are a little more grounded
in I make a widget and I sell a widget
and then people buy a widget
this we're here you're you know creating
the inner life of characters you're
casting people to go from nothing to
have the heights of glamour and fame and
power that is really corrupting and it's
it's hard to keep a rein on that and
well it remains to be seen if Hollywood
will be able to institute any kind of
culture of accountability I'm not very
hopeful for it but excellent excellent
analysis Perez thank you for being on
we've got to bring you back you you're
like the expert on all of these issues